[Music]
hello everyone thank you so much for
coming to listen to me today
my name is Sandra Anouk and I am a
project researcher in a one-year project
in a collaboration between the
University of Amsterdam's Faculty of Law
information law specifically an ethical
news data science division so let's talk
about news news is important news is
crucial in the way that we view the
world and therefore also influences the
important decisions that we make for
example who we're going to vote for
during election time but there is just
so much news the New York Times by
itself publishes 1,100 articles a day
and not even the most dedicated reader
can keep up with all these news let
alone that they could compare the
articles from the New York Times with
articles from a different media source
with maybe a different political
allegiance so because of this we have
come to rely on recommenders recommender
this come in very different shapes and
sizes and they help us determine which
stories are relevant for us to read so
for example on the front page of a
newspaper example the Dutch New Darnell
there could be a list of articles that
the editors think are important for
everybody to know and read once you have
selected an article a different
recommender could pop up and give you a
list of other articles that might be
interesting given that you have already
read this particular article
and lastly getting much more traction
recently our personalized recommenders
the recommenders that think okay for
this particular user we think they might
be interested in this particular subject
but recently a lot of concerns have come
up about filter bubble so in the most
famous example of this the most famous
TED talk about this subject the speaker
noted that on his Facebook page he would
only see post Democratic posts from his
Democratic friends for the Republican
friends had fallen off the radar
apparently since Facebook filtered his
newsfeed in such a way that he would
only get to see either the things that
he similar to things that he had seen
before or that his Democratic more
closest Democratic friends had liked he
wouldn't he only saw things and
articles that reflected already his
personal opinion and therefore filtered
him from didn't expose him enough to
other opinions and this is inherent how
the current approaches on recommender
systems work most kumamon is recommend
something that the user has already seen
before or the other one collaborative
filtering if so for me that would be I
would get to see articles that utter
20-something white females living in
Amsterdam had seen and this works
perfectly fine for product
recommendations in in web shops but in
news because it's so important kind of
needs to be held with slightly different
standards than run-of-the-mill
products you can buy so this was the
start of the project that we started
last September at University of
Amsterdam to Divini do want to develop a
tool that media companies could use to
evaluate the recommendations that they
generate and other than that good luck
so what we decided to do was to scrape
all news articles from Dena three
different very different media sources
from 2017 in XML elasticsearch we would
generate some baseline recommendations
for the ideas that they could serve as
comparison for the media company they
could compare their own recommendations
with these baseline and then calculate
the diversity and visualize this in a
easy-to-understand manner but then you
kind of get to the crux of the matter
because what is diversity for diversity
is an incredibly complex concept that
kind of really depends on who you ask I
bet a lot of the people here today
expected me to come to have a whole talk
about gender bias or a minority
representation for example there then
again if you ask a Everage computer
scientist diversity and tells her to
entropy and long sale representation and
popularity but these metrics don't
really make sense in the context of news
so what do you do I would like to
introduce you to the concept of a
normative framework which is something
that I had never heard of before I
actually walked into the university in
number but it's kind of what these
information a lot of people do they
develop a model of what the world should
look like how should it be the different
choices that you have and then with
their they're all over there are
advantages and disadvantages and to that
just establish what we think the world
should be and my job here is to look at
this normative framework that they
constructed for a democratically you say
that proper recommender and turn it into
something that can be quantifiable for
computers so this is what they came up
with and which normally which framework
you choose is very much dependent on the
media company and that in the role that
they assumed towards the users so for
example if they assume that in the end
the user just knows what is best for
them it is perfectly fine to make your
recommenders based on user clicks or
interaction time it may basically means
anything goes and if it makes the user
interact with our newest platform longer
that's great that's all that we want
it's perfectly fine and if the user also
only sees but the popular articles then
again if you were to follow the
participatory framework you assume more
of a paternalistic role you educate you
users towards everything that is out
there in society it becomes very
important that your recommender also
reflects all the other opinions that are
out there in the world the common good
trumps self-interest in this sense and
it has a decided larger focus on
political articles than for example the
liberal framework would have then you
have the deliberative and a
constructionist framework which are
slightly more similar to the
participatory framework whereas the
deliberative model would be more focused
on me as a particular user and
challenging me in particular so if I am
a left-wing usually it would assume okay
she knows all about the the left-wing
opinions out there in society let's give
her more right-wing stuff to look at and
the constructionist all the way and it
also it's still very factual biased in
the end is its focus on
agreeing to disagree know what is out
there become open-minded but we don't
all have to think the same thing the
construction is on the other model is
focus is under the good thing about
conflicts in a do in a Democratic
Society conflict is very important
because it challenges us it refines our
way of thinking etc here the
constructionist model will assume that
you already that the most popular are
things out there are already known and
it focuses on the minority voices the
very emotive and maybe even angry
content you get to see views that you
did not know before that they existed or
if you are a person yourself with a very
minority view it might enable you to
find different people with the same
ideas and principles so when we started
the project a very first thing it was
very important to do is expectation
management because all these things that
we discussed before are very high level
and abstract and we did not have data
not any data at all it's the only thing
that we have is plain text news articles
maybe with publication publication date
and if you're lucky and author and given
a highly volatile nature of news it
changes every day that there's makes no
sense to apply any kind of machine
learning on this if anybody disagrees
please come find me after us and even
more so to articles that are about the
same thing but from different sources
are also completely different so new dot
nell short messages very to-the-point
factual things delve very angry emotive
indeed and uses very different
terminology than other mains mainstream
news sources and evokes contents to be
much more elaborative but also left
Orientis oriented so the first step was
to look go back to these models and try
to determine each one what can we
actually measure from this we kind of
already accepted that we're never going
to get a perfect representation of any
of this but let's just see how far we
can get so if you want to measure
anything about how well you're doing in
terms of the liberal model you could
look at person
how much are my recommendations
different from the next users then again
in the participatory model but the
common good kind of implies that
everybody needs to know the same thing
so there will be less personalization
going on it would have more political
articles you had have a vocabulary that
is matched to your intelligence level
and ideally all ideas that are out there
in society should be in there the same
with the deliberative model you focus
more on impartial non emotional speech
may be slightly larger representation of
minorities and a constructions model
very emotional very angry but you can
already see a lot of problems out there
because for a person for a human it's
already very difficult to keep track of
all the opinions out there in the world
I I wouldn't know for if you give me a
random statement about something that's
going on in news today I wouldn't be
able to place it on any kind of map
access etc so how should a computer
start doing this so that is why we
decided to start very simple with very
trivial metrics maybe even and try to
build up from that because currently
there is nothing out there other than
information by user clicks we don't have
any way of evaluating our
recommendations so anything that's there
is already improvement so we started
with like I described personalization
calculations which is of importance to
liberal and participatory model we
visualized popularity the writing style
for Kevin the complexity of an article
which was an algorithm that was already
developed at CL news and we want to see
if there's plenty of different stories
represented in your recommendations so
we visualize this in cabana and that
could look something like this so you
see we have the three different
recommendation styles that we chose
which are really really rudimentary
really simple so random just picks a
number of random articles to display to
the user and is therefore kind of a
representation of this the things that
are in your data set overall most
Euler which is based on the number of
times the article has been shared of on
Facebook well just gives everybody the
same articles because everybody but it's
the same just as popular everywhere and
the more like this is a very simple is
based on elastic search more like this
algorithm so we simulates a couple of
users and reading history and I'm based
on this query that would recommend the
Articles that are most similar to this
so what you can see here well of course
the purple one is the the most popular
one but everybody gets the same thing so
all the users aggregated of each other
end up in the same bucket their
complexity is on average 55 which is
range between 0 and 100 ok
more like this has more of a spread over
it probably because it is based on what
people have allegedly read before and
random well and then the problem here is
ok now we have what does it mean what
does it mean to have a complex and
average complexity recommendations of 55
I don't know but the only thing that you
can do is you can compare the different
recommendation types with each other and
because of that you can kind of draw
some kind of conclusion and where do I
want to be what do I want to be what do
I want my recommendation to so this is
one approach you can take you can
aggregate it over users in total or you
can look at the things over time now you
can see very clear trend this is about
what was this again the length of the
article well you can clearly see that
the more like this algorithm tends to
recommend much longer articles then the
most popular and in random articles does
it mean something I don't know I cannot
determine that for the for the media
companies they have to decide it for
themselves so this kind of worked ok it
covered some of the bases that we
identified in our frameworks but we
wanted to get a little bit more than
that I discussed before that designing
on the topic would probably kind of be
impossible but we tried to think of a
way how can we approach a topic in a
different way
so what we tried to do is take order the
full text that we have applied Spacey's
dutch names and ste recognition
on it and try to see what we can
determine from the entities that we find
in in the article we combine this once
we found a person we would look this
person up on wiki data and from wiki
data then you can request / if if the
person is known you can ask for their
occupation and once we found politicians
within the occupation we would also try
to request which party they belong to
and which position they currently held
in government or whatever and here you
can also see that for example you're the
more like this algorithm becomes green
that it has a much larger representation
of politics articles than the other ones
do which is can really draw conclusions
from that because we have also seen in
the slide before that more like this
typically had longer articles so there
are stands to reason that they also talk
more about they mentioned more people in
their articles also a person we see that
I don't think you can really read it but
here this one reads politicians then you
have soccer players singer actor writer
etc we also don't really account for the
fact that people can be multiple things
at once
however again it is about the comparison
here
and it's not perfect but it is start
towards may be identifying opinions
because if you can see somebody is a
politician and he belongs to this party
maybe the next step could be to
aggregate them and see if people get
enough use from the different political
parties something similar but less into
it if we try to do the same thing with
location and then we use OpenStreetMaps
to request for more detailed location
geo points for example and this is the
replace a coordinate on a map for each
location that we found this is for one
particular recommendation type and here
you could see a little bit of difference
that one one of the recommenders
mentions a lot more articles about
brussels therefore probably larger focus
on EU politics by the way this is dot
here that's just the average coordinate
for the netherlands so that also doesn't
mean much
but again it's a start now we come into
more experimental metrics that we're
looking at right now so it really
interested in this thing about emotive
content but how do you how can you make
a computer decide if an article is
emotional or factual but one theory
that's out there is that emotive speech
contains less articles and prepositions
and more pronouns I'm not really sure
yet to what extent is this difference is
really significant that's something that
we're looking into right now but if we
can make this work that would be very
helpful in the in our metrics for the
for the different frameworks and lastly
we have a master student that's trying
to apply language patterns to actually
extract opinions and the people that
they that hold them she is a background
in linguistics
so she annotated a lot of data for a
source and content of a particular
opinion and our end goal is to in the
end
apply on this on new news article
articles and extract more from that so
yeah theory is always like a straight
line you kind of think okay this is how
we're going to do it but of course it
always turns out to be much more
complicated than that especially since
this is a one-year project for very
multidisciplinary there's also full
four-year PhD projects that try to solve
this and to be honest I also don't think
they're going to come up with the
perfect solution in the end but we need
to start somewhere there is nothing
there yet so any insights that we can
currently get into our news
recommendations is already a step
forward many more things that we would
like to do given the time and resources
we want to board more and more
sophisticated metrics and the activating
language I'm personally very interested
in trying to see if within our
recommendations we can determine which
articles about the same event because I
also think that it would be very very
beneficial we need to test and refine
this we're currently talking to multiple
media companies to try to see if we can
apply these principles on their actual
data which would probably be much more
interested than on my largely simulator
data and in the end from the university
there's also a lot of interest in trying
to make this more user facing so that
the end user could see okay so my media
diet how do I end up in the spectrum and
I getting enough diverse recommendations
so all in all initial exploration much
more research needed but I really what I
really like about this project is the
multidisciplinary part of it so these
people these information a lot of people
there's a wealth of research that's
already gone on in this area that's
currently unused by us technical people
and the technical people have the skills
to actually make this work and do
something with this so my recommendation
would be try to talk to them sometimes
because they're actually quite funny
sometimes sometimes when they don't talk
about privacy in any case I do think
this was a relatively short presentation
but it's also because I think it's very
interesting for open discussions I'm
also very interested in hearing what you
think and if you have any suggestions
about this so please
[Applause]